President Putin and other world leaders
in Moscow to commemorate the end of
World War two in Europe next Robert
service discusses the early life of
Soviet leader Joseph Stalin this is 25
minutes I'm very pleased to introduce
tonight Robert service is a fellow at
the British Academy and st. Anthony's
College at Oxford University he is
currently on sabbatical working through
the Hoover Institute in the archives
working on his current work in progress
communism a world history its previous
works include Lenina biography in a
history of modern Russia I quote from
foreign affairs magazine which came out
this is about February this year on this
latest book Stalin a biography where
they say service provides the most
wide-ranging description yet of what has
happened to Russia since it emerged from
the rubble of the Soviet Union hardly an
angle has been neglected from the
historical lineage of national identity
and the residue of Soviet times to the
excesses of popular culture and life in
the village the core of the book deals
with politics the character and failings
of Russia's leaders turning points in
the struggle over reform the
manipulation of symbols and media
relations between the center and
outlying regions it's a rich book and
variegated portrait of a wondrously
complex society a sympathetic abused at
times brutish people and a modern
leadership given to squandering
opportunity ultimately though and
Foreign Affair says service stresses the
successes and the failure ending with a
balance sheet that inclines him to
cautious pessimism please join me in
welcoming Robert service
I think it might be an idea to start by
saying why I came to write this this
further book beyond the one that's just
been described this biography of Stalin
because after all there are dozens of
biographies of Joseph Stalin and it's
obvious why there are dozens of
biographies of Joseph Stalin he took a
an agrarian country at the end of the
1920s and industrialized it he embarked
on a type of rule that involved regular
mass terror and yet that same country
achieved a victory a military victory
over Nazi Germany that would have been
inconceivable without the Soviet
participation at the end of the Second
World War the USSR was one of the two
superpowers that dominated the globe and
Stalin's USSR became a model for States
in Eastern Europe and for the People's
Republic of China and one man dominated
Soviet politics in in that period and
that man was Joseph Stalin so it's easy
to see why people have written or been
attracted to writing biographies of
Joseph Stalin those biographies follower
a conventional pattern the usual story
is that Stalin was a mere bureaucrat
that he had no ideas no talent was a
singularly uncultured man that he wasn't
really a believer in Marxism Leninism
that he was pathologically devoted only
to the aggrandizement of his own power
that he had a sort of split life a
bureaucrat in the first half of his life
who turned out in the second half of his
life to be a pathological killer that's
one thing I think that the biographies
haven't really previously tackled I
thought that it was worth having a go to
another biography not just because
archives have now opened up that were
previously closed to us and not just
because now we can go more easily to
Abkhazia where he he had his holidays or
to Georgia where he spent his childhood
or to parts of even Moscow that were
previously forbidden to us I thought it
was worth having another attempt at a
new portrait of this man because I
thought that most of the conventional
picture was unconvincing so I started
with the idea that it would be good to
use the new archives it would be good to
visit the bits of the old Soviet Union
that Stalin had been to and lived in but
also because I thought a new image of
the man a new picture of the man that
needed to be written
usually biographies skip over the first
15 or 20 years of his life in the first
two or three pages and yet you only have
to think about anybody that you know to
feel that actually most people are
formed are pretty well formed people by
the time they hit the age 20 so I
thought I'd spend a lot more time on the
childhood the family the Georgian
nationhood and I found that this was a
man who wasn't uncultured he was
actually a bit of a child prodigy he was
a published poet in his teens
not when he became powerful but actually
in his teenage years themselves and he
wasn't rejected he wasn't downtrodden he
was selected for the priesthood which
was one of the ways of getting
well-educated in Georgia in the south of
the Russian Empire in that period and so
talented was he that his poems went into
Georgia school textbooks before the
first world war before he was even known
widely as Stalin he was someone who had
a driven urge to go on educating himself
so when he lost his religious faith he
acquired a secular faith Marxism and he
stayed a voracious reader of a racial
self educator he had a sort of way of
pretending that he was a mere
working-class boy a rough tough
communist unlike the rather delicate
souls who went into the emigration like
Trotsky and Lenin and others but
actually he was much more like them than
he pretended it was part of his image to
rise up the Communist Party he was also
I found much more important among the
Marxists of the former Russian Empire
than had generally been accepted and the
reason for this was that the people who
wrote the history books wrote the
memoirs were people who hated Stalin
they were also people who had lived
abroad so they tended to look down on
the operators the marxist operators who
stayed in the Russian Empire and Stalin
was committed to making revolution in
the empire not from outside the Empire
he didn't like abroad he didn't like
foreign countries very much he liked the
Russian Empire he was drawn to the
Russian Empire
his homeland became bigger as his
Marxism became more important to him so
he started off as a Georgian patriot and
became a Marxist internationalist in the
Russian Empire with a commitment to
making Russian Russia the first place to
have the big socialist revolution the
importance of Stalin then was disguised
by the fact that he never became an
émigré that he was content to be a
clandestine militant but he rose to
prominence in the 1917 revolution he was
one of them the most important of
Lenin's left tenants and he ran the
Central Committee of the Bolshevik Party
when Lenin had to go into hiding one of
the things I think I found most
fascinating was that he had a poncho on
for terror he revealed this portion or
for terror in the civil war that
followed the October Revolution of 1917
he was notorious for the wasteful way he
conducted military strategy thousands of
peasants died unnecessarily in the Red
Army and thousands of peasants perished
because of the terror actions that he
directed against villages that were
thought to sympathize with the anti red
side he put officers on a barge officers
who were fighting in the Red Army for
the Red Army in 1918 because he hated
anything to do with the old Tsarist
order now this was against party policy
so he had this idea of surgically
removing elements social elements from
society even more excessive an urge than
his fellow Bolsheviks had so the idea
that there were two Stalin's there was a
sort of Starlin the bureaucrat up to the
end of the 1920s
and then Stalin the pathological killer
in the 1930s really doesn't stand up to
close scrutiny the other thing that came
across to me in the course of the
research was it was quite a surprise to
me really was how charismatic he was
what a great team leader he was how easy
it was for him to make himself appealing
to a sort of laddish rough crude element
inside the Bolshevik Party there really
was a Stalin team kaganovich Molotov and
several others were already recognizing
him as their leader well before he
became the dominant figure in Soviet
politics and when Lenin left his
testament saying that there would be two
men who would card in early fight for
the succession one would be Trotsky
everybody expected that the other would
be Stalin no one expected that but if
you look at the records Lenin wasn't
saying anything that already a lot of
people felt he was already a dynamic
leader not just a chief bureaucrat
inside the party and the memoirs that
Dan played this were memoirs by people
who had been beaten by Stalin and they
they they went out of their way to
portray sides of him that put them in
the good light rather than Stalin there
was something of the leader and not just
the chief bureaucrat already in the
1920s the other thing that I think needs
to be adjusted in our picture of Stalin
is that we think of him as being
irrational now I did go around
to several psychiatrists in writing this
book I have to say it gets to you it's a
it's a very gruesome
it does actually get to you but the
reason I went to psychiatrists was
because I was bothered by the number of
biographers who said that Stalin was mad
and it seemed to me that this was worth
looking at because it's a bit of a
cop-out if he was mad
then it more or less winds up all need
for explanation he was a pathological
killer psychiatrists tended to when I
told them the details of what I knew
about his psychology tended to confirm
that he would not now be called mad by
psychiatrists actually they don't use
the word mad they use the word psychotic
he would not be called psychotic what he
had was a gross personality disorder and
that means that he doesn't get off with
what he did it means that he had a
maladjusted focus on the way he saw the
world around him and what I tried to
bring out in this biography is that the
world around him was dangerous to him to
his party and to the Soviet state there
were millions of people who hated Stalin
he had some reason to move against them
to repress them if you had the kind of
ideology the kind of policies that he
had there were millions of peasants who
had been pushed into collective farms
who hated him there were hundreds of
thousands of members of other political
parties who had been suppressed and
thrown into the gulag
there were tens of thousands of priests
thousands of rabbis thousands of mullahs
and Imams who had landed up in
concentration camps
and all of their families didn't contain
very many admirers
of Joseph Stalin so when he launched the
Great Terror and in the end of the 1930s
far from it being a totally mad scheme
of repression it was a hugely excessive
reaction by a maladjusted leader to a
real existing genuine atmosphere of
hostility to him so the history of the
Great Terror really does need rewriting
because of the way that the state was
organized however he couldn't get the
victims that he wanted he told people to
go out for the the priests the mullahs
the the former Mensheviks the former
socialist revolutionaries the former
Trotskyites and so on the state system
however was not like Nazi Germany it was
chaotic and the people who were told to
arrest numbers of people and they were
given specific numbers of people to
arrest they just arrested up to that
number and they didn't worry too much
about the categories so that the history
of the great terror and the and the
career of Stalin are much more complex
than I think most of the biographies
have so far allowed there was something
very peculiar about this man
lots of people face lots of politicians
in history have faced pervasive popular
hatred and yet have not turned to the
methods that Stalin used so I'm not in
any way downplaying his peculiar
peculiarity he had a vengeful side that
we all know about
he lived in a marriage that was bound to
make him more edgy than it would
otherwise have been his wife had all
manner of mental problems he treated her
badly so he made those problems worse
so the marriage became worse the
marriage became more jumpy and less
congenial and his wife eventually could
take no more and killed herself and
after that he turned in on himself
became more and more distrustful of
everyone around him so this man who
already had a gross personality disorder
hid conditions that made him more edgy
more suspicious more vengeful and made
the terror worse than it probably would
even have been he was however a believer
the thing that really took me while
doing the research and looking at his
books he was a he was a real peasant he
took notes on everything he read he was
also a bit of a delinquent so he marked
all the books that he read and he wrote
his reactions in the margins so he
didn't write book reviews but he wrote
in the margins of the books and you can
see the care with which he read Lenin
Marx angles it's inconceivable that this
man didn't really believe this stuff so
that pictures of him azan someone who
turned into a world statesman who just
pragmatically adjusted himself to
whatever the current deals were that he
could do with Roosevelt or Truman or
Churchill or aptly or or motsek tongue
they miss part of the point he did do
those deals he did think pragmatically
but underpinning everything else was an
ideological commitment to Marxism
Leninism or as his own propagandists
called it Marxism Leninism Stalinism he
himself knew that this cult was
ludicrous this cult of him
the leader was ludicrous he periodically
said look don't issue so many books
about me don't don't put up so many
posters of me and he hath believed it he
hath believed that it had gone too far
but the people who were organizing the
cult around him they knew that if they
didn't issue those books if they didn't
pin up those posters they'd be for the
high jump so it was a complicated
psychological game that was going on
inside Stalin's head and a ruthless
political interplay that was going on in
the broader world of social politic of
Soviet politics he ruled in a way that
was always going to be despotic once he
got power
he totally identified himself with the
October Revolution as its Savior as the
new Lenin he maintained his power by a
totalitarian system that imposed a
vertical chain of command from the party
through the public institutions of the
army and the government right down to
the smallest little agencies of
statehood but that power was exercised
only for periods in a regular
predictable way because in order to to
control the Red Army to control the
Communist Party to control these great
economic ministries he needed to keep
all the fellow rulers his subordinates
on their toes so at the same time as
introducing totalitarian regularity and
uniformity he maintained total
unpredictability utter chaos he didn't
want anybody near him to think that they
had a steady job
he arrested the wives of some of the
Politburo members he shot the brother of
kaganovich he arrested the wife of
Molotov none of them knew whether at the
end of the Working Day they were going
to be at home in their dachas or or
inside the Lubyanka prison in central
Moscow being tortured to confess to
imaginary crimes so this was a very very
idiosyncratic murderous system the last
question that I wanted to deal with in
the biography and it was a question that
had intrigued me for many years was how
did this system relate to the way the
Soviet Union was ruled lower down the
system outside the Kremlin and what I
found there which confirmed a lot of
what I'd been thinking about in writing
earlier books on the Soviet Union was
that he didn't have total control I
don't think any ruler can have total
control but Stalin was so so vengeful so
murderous so brutal in the way that he
intruded in the public life of the
Soviet Union that it was natural for his
subordinates especially those who
weren't in his sight to find all sorts
of ways of wriggling out of doing
exactly what he wanted it was a
self-protection mechanism if they wanted
to survive they couldn't do everything
he wanted all of the time
so they chose the things that they would
do they picked and they chose and they
hope they chose correctly there were
little systems of patron and boss
sorry patron and client which protected
people in the localities little nests of
of institutional groupings whereby
people survived this manic system so
Stalin knew that this was going on he
knew that he could he knew that he
couldn't really even trust all of the
information coming up to him this was
not a perfect system of information it
was not a perfect system therefore it
couldn't be if you don't get perfect
information when you're running an
economy that big without any private
sector at all then you can't have
perfect commands so that he he tried to
perfect it one of the reasons he
launched the Great Terror was to get rid
of perceived enemies another was to
perfect the totalitarian system he found
that he couldn't he found that he was
just wiping out generation after
generation of officials and the system
stayed the same so he became ironically
in the end a communist conservative he
put up with the 90% of the results that
he wanted and he settled for that he
never got total control but for people
near him that didn't make any difference
they were terrified of him people very
near to him also respected him even
admired him so the Molotov wept when he
died
Molotov whose wife whom he dearly loved
was in prison and about to be tortured
and him involved in an anti-semitic
trial yet that same person Molotov
deeply deeply mourned his passing this
man Stalin was I wouldn't say he's in it
and enigma
there wouldn't be any point in writing
the book if he still thought there was a
mystery but he was complex he was
certainly not the unimpressive
uncultured bureaucrat of the
conventional biographies and that's why
I thought it was worth writing as bigger
a doorstep as I've written it's always
useful to throw around when you're in a
an angry mood or prop open a door but I
hope it has more purposes than that
thank you
yeah I'll be delighted
thanks all all of you for coming
Roberts services author of Lenin a
biography and a history of modern Russia
his latest Stalin of biography is
published by Harvard University Press
visit hup harvard.edu